well let's move on now and get some
ration from labor shall we because on
the show today we also spoke to the show
defense secretary John Healy I did move
on to the NATO Summit but I started by
asking about the naming a few Edwards
she's taken the decision to do that
um
these are serious allegations and
they've quite clearly taken a terrible
toll on the alleged victims and their
families and also on Hugh Edwards and
his family I hope the temperature can be
taken out of this now and that the level
of speculation and attention can be
reduced and allow the BBC to do what
they need to do now which is fully
investigate the allegations and do that
without any more delay that's
interesting do you think that they're
part of the issue was that BBC were slow
of the Mark if you like well up until
today it was in the hands of the police
so the BBC had to stay their
investigation
um
now they need to pick this up they need
to get to the bottom of the allegations
and
in the meantime I think we can all have
a great deal of concern for those
victims alleged victims and their
families and also
for Hugh Edwards and his family too what
do you think is serious about the
allegations
I think the
do you know I really don't want to get
into that in the sense that it it's a
complicated story they've been
conflicting reports
um and this now needs to be bottomed out
so the rest of us are I think best
served
um by allowing the BBC to do that and
waiting for the
full facts actually to be established
the question marks about how the BBC's
handled this obviously the initial
allegation from the mother
um she said that she did go to the BBC
but nothing happened well the reports
have been conflicting haven't they as
well as confusing to those not involved
and part of a very complicated story so
um I'm sure the BBC will first and
foremost want to sort out the
investigation in these allegations but
we'll want to look at its processes to
make sure that it's able to do these
promptly and professionally in the
future
um just looking at the statement that
we've had
um about Hugh Edwards from his wife she
says that she was suffering from serious
mental health issues the events the last
few days have greatly worse and matters
he suffered another serious episode and
he's now receiving inpatient hospital
care where he'll stay for the
foreseeable future
do you feel sorry for him
I think we've got to all do now what
she's also asked for which is
privacy and respect
um so that these matters can be properly
settled and that's the BBC's job okay
now let's talk about NATO has it been a
successful meeting do you think
it's been a very successful Summit in my
view the first Focus has properly been
on Ukraine
um and there are
uh there's been a big boost to the
military help available to Ukraine now
but also some important longer term
security agreements in place and the
bilateral agreements that through the G7
Britain is going to be a part of have
our full labor support I think equally
significant
has been the
reboot of Defense planning
that NATO has undertaken in order to
deal with Russian aggression we may face
over the next decade and above all the
unity of the NATO Nations so the NATO
has come out stronger
it's come out more unified and it's come
out bigger of course with the accession
of Sweden as well as Finland as new
members and those things are the very
last things that President Putin would
have wanted to see
they're always quite carefully
choreographed and we've had something
that has
blown some of that choreography out and
I'm talking about the comments by Ben
Wallace defense secretary who said that
ukrainians need to show gratitude
towards countries providing them with
weapons he says I said to the ukrainians
last year when I drove 11 hours to be
given a list of weapons that they want I
said I am not Amazon
would make that
for me the most important thing is the
ukrainians are fighting for the freedom
and future of their country
and president zielinski wants more
military help yesterday of course he
does
and I think the last thing he needs is
public lectures about gratitude
particularly as they also overshadow a
successful NATO Summit which has left
NATO stronger and has given Ukraine
greater security not just immediate
military help but some of the
reassurances and agreements they'll need
it's very measured how you talk about
all these things but at the same time
like you know we're kind of if you look
at what's happened president zielinski a
guy who has his Contour has been invaded
by Russia he's seen playgrounds being
grown up blown up we've all seen the
pictures of apartment blocks demolished
he's been told he should be more
grateful
extraordinary things so important to be
measured
um he's a war leader displaying great
courage as the ukrainians have in their
fights civilians and Military alike what
he's also said and this for me is the
most important thing he said at the end
of the summer it is that this is a
significant security victory for Ukraine
for our people and for our children okay
um
finally I just want to talk to you about
public sector pay because the peer
review bodies are making recommendations
the Armed Forces of course are tied up
in this and we understand that the pay
rise is around six to six point five
percent for them would labor Grant it
well the average value of all workers
pay has foreign
we haven't seen the pay review bodies
that the governments have for some time
um that's a decision for the government
now and a responsibility for the
government now would you be lost
you say you're the government this is
the Army going to be listening to this
kind of answer sure would you be in the
year of the chancellor saying these guys
need to be top of your list they need
they need six percent we need to accept
the pay review bodies I'm just trying to
get a sense of you know if you want to
be defense secretary after the election
what kind of Defense secretary are you
going to be
I'll be a defense secretary that
restores the moral contract this nation
makes with those who serve and their
families but at this stage we haven't
seen this year's pay review body
we don't know how the government's going
to respond they've still got the Autumn
statement and the spring statement next
year we don't know what inflation is
going to be like we don't know what the
state of the economy is going to be like
what we do know and if you had a labor
government they would be taking the pay
review body review reports seriously
they would be bringing round the table
those who need to sort out the
settlements for the future and it isn't
just about pay it isn't just about
paying the forces just like it isn't for
the NHS or for teachers they're worried
about recruitment retention Workforce
load and high level of vacancies thank
you very much bigger problems the
responsibility of the ministry